this is the master plan here he put
different weapons that they need with
Kalashnikovs you hear that there are a
lot of ways to to rob banks
I understand all my projects in a
political way but in all the projects I
collaborate with people who are creating
situations and actions in 2008 the
collapse of the Spanish housing bubble
plunged the country into deep recession
the banks were using risky strategies to
generate huge profits against the
potential value of a housing market with
its collapse the banks failed and the
consequences were passed on to the
Spanish people
it was at this time Catalan artists new
react well returned to her hometown in
Spain with a Cuban partner and creative
Calabria levy otter in this sense I ask
that all of these projects related with
financial issues to make visible powder
the lungs works and with levy weak start
own speculate that how we can make a
project these we say well we can rub
about and say that that is a piece of
art now for this idea to work they were
gonna need some help someone with
experience in a shared distaste for the
system an accomplice in from a celebrity
bank robber and proclaimed man of the
people
hi Meg our bay AKA el salat area has
robbed over 30 banks in 2007 he was
apprehended in his signature disguise of
a false beard
mr. sham wig he is currently serving a
47 year prison sentence this gave
nearing an idea it was a long shot but
she had nothing to lose mystic art
Atelier Gaara espero que si medicos her
proyectos artistic owes me gustaría
mucho poder al assad otro en
collaboration contigo los dos fritos
tienen como objetivo poder des Villar an
evil so she al la perverse incheon area
financier a conic a proceeding los
bank-owned actualmente su privilegio a
tirado por el estado en koala sclavi
Santo de la población
y su falta veticon la Sol Sierra so this
is the study and a place where we work
here have a lot of investigations of
different projects
kiss climates very jokey yeah always
when the police and take crime and take
photos he put like different expressions
in the face no these photos no work for
the police
you know when rubber band hey say Merry
Christmas no and go under people do no
identification the media make a lot of
efforts to criminal criminally dry
climate in a we go public on
No
there was no way to be certain if any
letter would reach highway and even if
it did whether he would be able or
willing to reply but then several weeks
later Nuria cuenta con MIGO para lo que
se considera Norma meant a importantes
smskull are a todos OS criminales del
Ivanka justice complete assisted honest
la gente tiene que salad la gente tiene
correctional la gente tiene que su
Gibson and they start ludicrous iya desk
are Nala and desta stock kleptocratic
co-leaders sh o or a democratic election
kick him conspiring together and our
piece was conceived to build a master
plan contained in many ways to go up
over the central bankers in Spain this
is a plan to break ATM and take all the
money without this machine invalid the
money
Sara la ya la passerelle God is Asteras
is a yak Tyra's dentro de rigueur
automatic Oh cuando la cuenta Mosca's
injected o más fuertes explosion salute
amore liberty' health love and freedom
the pupil that work in the jail see the
letters between us they informed the
police and the letters on don't arrive
sure my name is in the black list to the
police after communications were blocked
other covert techniques were needed
Jaime's mother began to help by
smuggling Maria's letters inside of Rome
and now with other inmates starting to
share their strategies a comprehensive
plan was beginning to take shape one
year every month one chapter and at the
end of the year we have all done on the
master plan note in here that there are
a lot of ways to to rob banks here he
put different weapons that they need
kalashnikov's sometimes are a little bit
spectacular no like a movie no they go
for la sua and here there are them the
big save many people say that they can
believe all that we explained with the
project that no is real but is
belly of the elf now in possession of
this potentially incriminating piece of
art a safe place was required to store
it and we're better than the safety
deposit box of the very same Bank the
plans proposed to rob I knew I'd know
what we putting in the safe and then a
bank never asked what we putting in the
safe if you have money you can buy a
space of import impunity a lot of money
drugs never ask those interests are
poner sol de la mesa Kemal van Colette I
Wallis consequences so fearless of
political economic escape a tenor Sue's
acciones solo Lane Teresa general
benefits is no hostile punto de el
viernes esta casa fuerte para who are
there in soon protections alguna manera
goodnight romantic a Sunnah possibly
Rocky se puede volver in contra ellos
mismos no it's curious because five
years ago on the pupils have a lot of
respect and now the pupil change the
perception these banks of power because
in this time we give a lot of power to
these to these corporations no and if we
change these and we put our money other
ones with other ethical prospective
these banks lost money and this only
depends of the project is finished when
we sell de the master plan in the actual
house now the final element of the
projects in presentation of the art is
this the key that opens the safety
deposit box this key exposes a risky
strategy for generating extreme wealth a
value based on the potential reward of
the master plan and that keys value is
left to be decided by the highest bidder
these very metaphoric about how monks
war use the same strategies that the
capitalistic system use to fight
arranged capitalism
I think that is a good tool that allows
us to rethink how we work as a society
no bangs no work in the years before the
financial crisis of 2008 the rich world
was floating on a wave of private debt